[Music]
my name is Roger factor I'm a
conservationist working for the Wildlife
Conservation Society most of my weekend
actually when I'm not busy doing some
other thing on conservation
I'm our bird-watching we are inside the
color for us today just about 20
kilometer outside of the only the
capital city of Cameroon we are looking
for the Great Neck picker turtle which
is a very special bird the grande
Pickett artist looks just like a big
pigeon with long legs and a long tail
but have this special feature that the
head is very colorful have no fit on the
head but rather have patches of bright
red and blue separated by black that
goes over the art and this actually
contrasts very well with the gray back
and the yellowish belly when you happen
to spot the bird in the bush that looks
quite nice is the magic about this bird
because of his second see he's unique
he's not like any other bird
this is a typical nesting site for the
picket artist our first seriousness in
1995 he always started with a bit of mud
then they have to find a crack at
crevice where they can actually hang
what is starting to put them up because
this part of the mud actually is added
all the years that's what I make the
nests in aim big and strong so they
revisited every year it's hard work you
really have to love this to do it one
thing people have to realize the attack
of the sixth month of the bird to
complete such an ass we're looking for
this bird and we hope to be able to see
it today because it is a very elusive
quiet and secretive bird
the green apricot have this very strict
habitat requirement and the veg
sensitive to any kind of disturbances
finding this bird having a stable and
good population it's a good indication
that the surrounding habitat may be in
good shape
[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
we have one of the best most important
population of the green etiquette
artists in Cameroon and so close to
yonder there's a high risk and serious
pressure coming from land development
it's a typical illustration of illegal
logging because this tree has just been
fell in front of the cave where the
green a picket art has been nesting fun
is the past twenty fourteen years so
it's damaging it's not just that you
know they're cutting the tree the
opening of the area the putting extra
pressure on these bird species we can
understand sometimes that people try to
make some living but this is not the
right way of doing this there's a need
for protecting this forest you have many
many plants in this that people are
using adapt for medicine or for food
this is the water screen for many of the
small River around this place so he
painted watershed is keeping the clean
air for the big city you can provide a
powerful education the next generation
of conservationists and biologists use
this as a laboratory for learning how to
better protect and tear forests of kamon
these forests still have the capacity
and the potential to recover if
protected
I hope that people can listen to this
and realize the importance of this piece
of forest and take the necessary step to
protect it
[Music]
[Music]